you
I am Eugenie Scott I'm the executive
director of the National Center for
Science Education we are in Oakland
California where a membership
organization most of our members are
scientists teachers people concerned
about church and state separation we
monitor the creationism and evolution
controversy and we try to help teachers
and school boards and legislators and
citizens to cope with pressures against
the teaching of evolution so in the 25
years or so that we've been doing this
we have found that there are three
arguments that pretty much any
creationist contention can be put into
if it's a video or a letter to the
editor our comment on a talk show
whatever it'll pretty much fall into one
of these three categories and we call
them the pillars of creationism I'd like
to tell you a little bit about the
pillars and why they're important to
recognize because you as a scientist or
a citizen who enjoy science who is
interested in science I hope is
concerned about what's going on in
American public schools and the science
classes there because at ncsc we hear a
lot about pressures from school boards
upon curriculum we hear pressures upon
individual teachers from parents we hear
about pressures from school boards or
state legislators that trickle down to
the classroom teacher as well and in all
of these cases there's there's been this
continuing story for over 30 years of
people who don't want kids to learn
evolution and even though the there have
been various ins and outs of the
creation and evolution controversy and
the creationists have always lost in
court this is an evolving targets
because creationism or shall we say in
response to the legal environment
there's a natural selection going on
here and we have different forms of
creationism and the current form of
creationism that we're coping with that
we're monitoring at NCSE today is
perhaps the most difficult to fight
because it doesn't appear to be the kind
of thing you can challenge directly in
court at any rate
get to that in a moment so let me tell
you about the pillars of creationism
because as a concerned citizen as a
scientist I hope you'd be able to
recognize them and understand the
refutations of the pillars so that you
can hopefully contribute to your own
community or state and help to improve
science education the first pillar is
the pillar which challenges the science
of evolution the claim is often made
that evolution is a theory in crisis
that scientists are giving up on
evolution that more and more scientists
are rejecting evolution as a failed
theory that will come as a surprise to
scientists but this is the claim that is
made and it's made very very loudly on
Talk radio's on blogs and letters to the
editor and so forth the second pillar of
creationism is an ideological pillar
it's the religious ideology that
evolution is incompatible with my
religious views therefore evolution
cannot be true and this takes various
forms the strongest form is if an
individual is a biblical literalist or a
qur'anic literalist this this point of
view is present and conservative
Christians conservative Muslims and
conservative choose the Middle Eastern
monotheism's if you will the argument is
made that my holy books when I look at
them I see special creation God created
everything especially in its present
form over a short period of time 6,000
years ago therefore evolution cannot be
true and indeed evolution is
incompatible with that particular
religious view some people reject
evolution because of a human
exceptionalism perspective that that
human beings are so superior to all
other organisms God must have created
especially there's a lot of ways that
that religion is used to oppose the
teaching of evolution the third pillar
is the fairness pillar the call it's a
cultural concept really it's a pillar
where the anti evolutionists are tapping
into some very deeply held american
cultural positions fairness balance free
speech
letting everybody speak you know town
hall meetings all that sort of thing and
and these are really great cultural
values there's nothing wrong with them
it's just that they are misapplied shall
we say when it comes to how we decide
what a kid's you learn in school now how
can you as a concerned citizen deal with
these three pillars as I say whatever
argument you hear you can probably fit
it into one of these three so if I can
just give you the generic refutations
then you can go from there there's
plenty of evidence for the particular
Zhaan various websites on NCS these
websites and others the evolution is
weak science pillar let's take a look at
that first well the best way to refute
that is to help your audience help the
person you're talking to understand that
in fact the consensus in the scientific
community supporting the idea that
evolution has happened the universe is
old etc is enormously strong there have
been many surveys of scientists there's
been a lot of survey research of
scientists showing upwards of the high
ninety percent of scientists accept the
idea of evolution it's hard to get
scientists to agree on whether it's
raining outside but there's this really
really strong acceptance consensus view
that evolution is valid science but the
public doesn't know this in the few
surveys that have been done where the
members of the public have been asked do
you think scientists agree that
evolution has happened the difference
between what the public thinks
scientists believe in what scientists
actually believe is like twenty thirty
percent it's really a big disconnect so
help the public understand that
evolution is valid science the second
pillar the religion pillar is best dealt
with by helping people understand that
there's a very wide diversity of opinion
within the Christian community I often
joke that I think more evolution is
taught in Catholic parochial schools
than in public schools because the
catholic church accepts something called
theistic evolution which is of course
evolution happened
but it was the gut way that God chose to
bring about the world according to his
plan there's varieties of theistic
evolution out there but it's basically
an idea it's a Christian theological
idea that is fully compatible with what
science shows us about living things
evolving through time Catholics
mainstream protestants official theology
is in fact theistic evolution so it is
not the case that if you are a Christian
you have to reject evolution some
Christian views absolutely but not all
Christian views most people think
there's a dichotomy on one side is
atheist evolution on the other side is
Christian creationism but that's false
that's just empirically wrong it's not a
dichotomy it's a continuum the third
pillar the fairness pillar is the most
difficult one to deal with because it is
so strongly rooted in American cultural
traditions the fairness pillar is best
dealt with by helping the public think
about this a little bit more more
carefully obviously we want debate in
our society about a lot of things people
should be free to express opinions
people should be free to argue
vehemently about one position or another
one opinion or another that's not really
what we're talking about what we're
really talking about is a much more
narrow issue we're really talking about
what do you teach in high school science
class because that is where these
policies that come to school boards or
the pressure that comes upon teachers
really come to what you should teach in
high school science class is no surprise
science and a high school science
teacher has the very important job of
picking from the huge array of subject
matter in say biology or physics or
chemistry or whatever that smaller range
of topics that is essential for young
learners who are just building an
understanding of that particular
scientific field in biology that one of
those core principles is evolution that
living things are related genetically in
this this huge genealogical tree of
living creatures through time
help the public understand that we're
not talking about inhibiting anybody's
free speech we're not talking about
science being dogmatic and and forcing
views upon students we're talking about
doing the same thing in high school
biology class as we do in physics or
chemistry or for that matter mathematics
and the English literature and geography
we teach the consensus view of the field
now if the creationists or the
intelligent design people or anybody
else who challenges evolution wants to
make the argument that they have a valid
science that deserves to be taught in
the public school classroom knock
yourself out but your job is to convince
the scientific community first what is
happening is that because of the
politicized nature of American education
curriculum decisions are made by elected
officials and elected officials are
looking over their shoulder two votes as
opposed to necessarily paying attention
to what's you know the best curriculum
because American education is
politicized there are pressures upon
teachers outside of science to change
the curriculum one way or the other they
should be protected from that students
should not be the the platform upon
which we fight the culture wars let the
creationists or the intelligent design
people or the anti evolutionists
demonstrate the scientific community
that they have valid views that
evolution is either a weak science or
that they've got a better alternative
and it'll trickle down to the high
school if it makes it into the consensus
they argue fairness frankly to teach
students that something is not valid
when there's such a strong scientific
consensus about it is the most unfair
thing you can do I would hope that being
familiar with the refutation zuv the
three pillars would give you more
confidence in standing up for good
science in your community if you hear of
a school board issue or some state
legislation or school board legislation
or if you even hear word that one of
your local teachers is reluctant to
teach evolution because
she or he feels that there's pressure
from the community I hope that you will
stand up for good science and the first
thing you can do is contact us at NCS
e-comm we can put you in touch with
people in your community who feel
likewise we can give you the ammunition
show we say the arguments that you can
use on the methods that you can use to
make a good argument to your local
decision makers because teachers need
help we're we get calls every week from
teachers who want some advice who want
some support to teach good science and
they deserve all the support that we as
scientists and concerned citizens can
give them thank you
you